let's now tackle Part C so they tell us
block three of mass M sub three so
that's right over here is added to the
system is shown below there is no
friction between block three and the
table all right indicate whether the
magnitude of the acceleration of block
two is now larger smaller or the same as
in the original two block system explain
how you arrived at your answer so let's
just think about the intuition here if
you think about the net forces on the
system itself they're the same as we had
before now they're the internal forces
are going to be different you actually
we're going to have two different
tensions now now that you have two
different strings but the net force is
the ones that are causing this thing to
accelerate to in in the upward direction
on the left hand side to the right on
the top and then downwards on the right
hand side it's still the the difference
in the weight between the two blocks but
now that difference in those in between
the weights of the two blocks is moving
more mass and we know that force is
equal to mass times acceleration or
acceleration is equal to force divided
by mass and our force our net force is
being is the differential between the
weights or the difference between the
weights of the block but now we're going
to be moving more aggregate mass this is
going to be M 1 plus M 2 plus M 3 and so
you're going to have a smaller
acceleration and so what you could write
is is acceleration acceleration smaller
because same difference difference in
weights in weights between M 1 and M 2
is now accelerating more mass
accelerating
more mass and that's the intuitive
explanation for it
and if you wanted to dig a little bit
deeper you could actually set up
Freebody diagrams for all of these
blocks over here and you would come to
that same conclusion so let's just do
that just just to feel good about
ourselves so what are on mass 1 what are
going to be the forces well you're going
to have the force of gravity which is
m1g then you're going to have the upward
tension pulling upwards it's going to be
larger than the force of gravity with in
a different color so you're going to
have whoops let me do it alright so
you're going to have this tension let's
call that t1 you're not going to have
two different tensions here because you
have two different strings now the
tension there is t1 the tension over
here is also going to be t1 so let me do
the same magnitude t1 now since block
two is a larger weight than block one
because it has a larger mass we know
that the whole system is going to
accelerate is going to accelerate in on
the right-hand side is going to
accelerate down on the left-hand side
it's going to accelerate up and on top
is going to accelerate to the right and
so at the top is accelerating to the
right then the tension in this second
string is going to be larger than the
tension in the first string so we did
that in another color so I'm having
trouble drawing straight lines all right
so that we could call t2 and if that is
t2 then the tension through so then this
is going to be t2 as well because the
tension through the the magnitude of the
tension through the entire string is
going to be the same and then finally we
have the weight of the block we have the
weight of block 2 there's going to be
larger than this tension so that is m2 G
now I've just drawn all the forces that
are relevant to the mag
to the acceleration if I wanted to make
a complete I guess you could say
Freebody diagram where I'm focusing on M
1 M 3 and M 2 there are some more forces
acting on M 3 M 3 in the vertical
direction you have its weight which you
could call m3g but it's not accelerating
downwards because the table is exerting
force it sit on it on an upwards
exerting and upwards force on it so of
the same magnitude offsetting its weight
so that's if you wanted to do a more
complete free body diagram for it but we
care we care about the things that are
moving in the direction of the
acceleration depending on where we are
on the table and so we can just use
Newton's second law like we've used
before saying the net force is in a
given direction are equal to the mass
times the magnitude of the acceleration
in that given direction so the magnitude
of that force is equal to mass times the
magnitude of the acceleration and so we
can do that first with block one so with
block one actually let me just do this
with specific so block one I'll do it
with this orange color so block one
what's the net forces well it is t1
minus m1g
that's going to be equal to mass times
acceleration so it's going to be m1
times the acceleration
now what about block three well block
three we're accelerating to the right
we're going to have t2 we did it in a
different color
block three we are going to have T two
minus T one minus T one is equal to M is
equal to M three and the magnitude of
the acceleration is going to be the same
here we're accelerating to the right
here accelerating up here we're slowing
down but the magnitudes are going to be
the same there all I can I can denote
them with this lowercase a and then
finally we could think about block three
we could say that the net force is well
that's m2 G minus t2 that's going
against m2 G is equal to
M two times its acceleration and now if
we want to solve for acceleration this
will be quite convenient we can just add
up all of the left-hand sides to get a
new left-hand side and add up all the
right-hand sides to get a new right-hand
side we can do that algebraically
because they're all this is equal to
that that is equal to that that is equal
to that so if you add up these and then
you add up those well then the the sums
are going to be equal to each other and
so what are you going to get so if you
add up all of this this t1 is going to
cancel out with subtracting the t1 this
2 2 is going to cancel out with the
subtracting the t2 and you're just going
to be left with an m2 G m2 G minus m1 G
minus m1g m2g minus m1 G is equal to and
just four well let me just write it out
is equal to m1 a plus m3 a plus m2 a but
we could of course factor the a out and
so let me just write this as that's
equal to a times m1 plus m2 plus m3 and
then we could divide both sides by m1
plus m2 plus m3 so let's just do that so
M 1 plus M 2 plus M 3 M 1 plus M 2 plus
M 3 these cancel out and so this is your
the magnitude of your acceleration and
notice you have the same difference in
weights that's providing the net force
on the system but is now accelerating
more mass so you can even say hey look I
have more mass here so a more mass to
accelerate more mass more mass to
accelerate while I have the same net
force acting on the system we're not
talk about the internal forces those all
canceled out when I when I when I added
these equations and so if you're if
you're taking the same net force and
you're dividing it by more mass you're
going to have a smaller smaller
acceleration hopefully that all made
sense to you